we have a Manifesto we have some
writings that we're going over that
pertain to this day the actual incident
but that's not all authorities found
cell phones laptops a suicide note three
folders and 19 journals
so why hasn't the public seen any of
this and do they really expect us to
believe that they can't establish a
clear motive behind Audrey Hale's
actions
but there's another curious development
as well the media are usually rabid
right about securing the release of the
shooter's Diaries or manifestos but
they've Fallen oddly silent oddly
incurious here why is that oh the night
of the shooting the angle spoke to FBI
criminal profiler about the issue what
he said stuck with us watch
they're gonna have to release all of
that James yes or no the all that's
going to have to be released to the
public
well Laura that's exactly where I was
going it should be released but I have a
feeling there may be some doj
participation in this they may not want
this kind of these kind of writings
going out it would destroy a bunch of
narratives that this President
Administration has
tonight that seems to be the only
conclusion that we can reach Metro
Nashville PD told the Ingram angle that
they along with the FBI are still
reviewing everything and there's no
timeline for its release
joining me now Charlie Kirk founder and
president of Turning Point USA Charlie
what's going on here
well yeah the buried lead there is that
if there's a lot to review probably and
then there's a lot that they don't want
actually to be put in the public think
of all the things that the media was
enthusiastic that got leaked or was
revealed in the last couple years the
president's tax returns illegally the
president's phone calls president Trump
not to mention the Supreme Court Leak
with Dobbs but we're not allowed to see
the manifesto there's been major pushes
by the media for transparency over the
last couple years that democracy
actually hangs in the balance but we
know why they don't want this to be made
public because there might be evidence
that number one that this was a hate
crime inspired by a trans ideology
against Christians number two there
might be further evidence that this
person was wrestling and struggling with
this ideology that this was not
necessarily this is something that might
have outside influences might have come
in maybe Tick-Tock or social pressure or
other ideas we don't know I'm
speculating at this point but the more
that the government is refusing to
release this Manifesto it begs the
bigger question what are they trying to
cover up and why
well isn't the Washington Post motto
democracy dies in the darkness right
yeah in the hours after the shooting
Charlie the media was already as you
remember downplaying the manifesto
this person had a so-called Manifesto
that maybe sounds like a kind of a
glorifying word for was probably just a
screed in a journal the word almost kind
of legitimizes what they're doing is if
it's some sort of legitimate uh
political stance or something it may not
make sense to a lot of people likely not
Charlie surprised here
well not surprised but I'm of course
disappointed you know if they would have
found in that Manifesto something about
the great replacement Theory or some
sort of white identitarian politics this
Manifesto be made public we know that
from the Buffalo shooter we know that
from the homicidal maniac in South
Carolina we know that through a pattern
of Shooters where the media not only
calls for the release but they do day
after day after day of headlines talking
about how these ideologies are creating
violence and yet when there's an
ideology they actually support that is
supported by the entire regime and the
mainstream media in our government
they're actively involved in covering
this up which is why I'm so glad we're
still talking about this Lord so thank
you we have to keep the pressure on we
have to keep on asking the questions and
eventually once enough time passes and
they have no more excuses if nothing is
done House Republicans need to subpoena
these documents for the FBI to make this
Manifesto public anything priority right
up there with all the other oversight
that Jim Jordan House Republicans are
doing yeah well they certainly got that
uh 21 year old Air Force Guardsmen they
found him pretty quick off that Discord
they certainly got on that fast didn't
they Charlie thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else